take a look at this story that's also
rather depressing
house democrats tout bill to add four
seats to the supreme court oh boy this
is them just saying we can't win
politically we can't win your votes nuke
the system and give us the power and if
they actually try to overturn or bypass
the filibuster
to stack four more seats and give joe
biden
four appointees
man this country just implodes what do
you what do you think what do you guys
think will happen if let's say in the
next session or whatever they say we're
over we're doing away with the
filibuster
we're pushing this bill through it gets
pushed through and then joe biden goes
one two three four new supreme court
justices what do you think the reaction
would be yeah well this this is uh
theatrics because manchin and cinema
already said they would not tank the
filibuster they don't have the votes for
it and and mansion and cinema both came
out and said they wouldn't uh allow
court packing so they know they don't
have the votes in the senate the house
doesn't have any jurisdiction in this
area right only the senate approves or
confirms justices
um so this is just this is desperate for
november to say hey vote for me because
i proposed a bill to add four justices
of the supreme court this is all
theatrics it's terrible the scenario
that you're painting is bad and we
shouldn't be playing these games it
reminds me of like playing with your
anyone you have a lot of brothers i was
the youngest of a whole bunch reminds me
of playing with your brothers as a kid
and when you're the baby and you keep
changing the rules because it's like not
fair you can only throw red ones and you
have to close your eyes and it's like by
the end the rules are so stupid but it's
basically because you're a loser and you
don't want to lose you want to prolong
the game and that's what they're doing
they just keep changing the rules to
prolong the game i suppose it's fair to
say obviously it'll never happen you
know yeah but we didn't think roe v wade
was gonna get overturned either and
that's well some some people did
yeah but most people didn't
ruth bader ginsburg was one she thought
it would be overturned eventually there
were a lot of conservatives they were
like there's no way they'll do it they
won't do it it's it's they didn't some
people thought it was going to happen
but most people didn't i mean i
maybe we had conversations but i thought
the attitude most people had was like
man i don't know i don't like i don't
think they'll have a spine for it
roberts will be opposed to it and and
then it happened and i didn't i think it
was going to happen but i will say at
the very least the bare minimum is we're
at the point where democrats are just
basically saying torch the system and
give us the power regardless of if
they're able to get it or not and so
if we keep moving in this direction it's
only a matter of time before
it spills over
and then there's there's i mean i got to
be honest i already think we're in the
territory of
you know it's just about seizing power
regardless of what matters for the
american people yeah
and what's frustrating about this is
that
roe is a clearly very dramatic decision
it's got a lot of impact i'm not at all
making light of it but there have been a
lot of supreme court cases which are
have way more impact on the average
american without them realizing it that
were decided poorly kilo versus new
london is the one that always comes to
my mind which was about eminent domain
right in the right for the the
government to seize your property for
the promise of of additional taxes that
if you go to times square in new york
right now you'll see all these signs
because the governor of of the state and
the mayor want to take over about 300
businesses around penn station because
they want to build a new 15 comp
building complex and they're like well
this is my little pizzeria and it's like
well we're going to take it because of
imminent domain and they legally have
the right because of kilo versus new
london it happens all the time eminent
domain is how government seizes your
property because tim wants to build a
condo there and the condo will pro
generate more taxes than your little
farm that's correct a terrible decision
so my point is the the courts have made
terrible decisions in the past scott was
one of the terrible decisions uh
korematsu was one of the terrible
decisions but we've never responded with
well therefore we have to blow up the
courts so it's just it shows you not
just the pettiness of the left right now
but it shows you the real ignorance of
them right politics is a slug match and
sometimes you win and sometimes you lose
and the system prevails for 246 years
but the fact that they're like well now
we don't want to play the game anymore
it's cultural decay it really is
and how do you how do you repair that
how do you how do you i don't know if
you can take back control of the money
system that's a good start like you said
at the beginning of the show forty
percent of people think the economy is
the biggest problem whereas one percent
thinks it's abortions zero percent what
was the other one we're talking about
climate change zero percent thinks it's
climate zero percent
but how many people are are going to try
and nuke the system for the economy well
i don't want to nuke it i just want to
fix it no no i'm not saying you do i'm
saying there are people who are looking
at abortion and maybe one percent but
those are people who are willing to
throw fireballs radicals
yeah
don't put don't put power in the hands
of radicals right now
yeah well there might be a time and a
place for it but uh not over what's
happening we need to focus on the
economy aoc 13 million followers and
she's growing and she's with that fake
handcuff thing it's clearly she's just
trying to manipulate people for power
she pretended to be handcuffed yeah
photo op thinks like if she can get
enough people behind her believing in
her then she can do the right thing
right thing yeah like when i should do
the right thing subversion to get people
on my side and then i'll do the one
thing i have agreed upon a greater agree
on her with was when she said some
someone police maybe open the doors from
the inside yeah but she's only saying
that because it personally impacts her
yeah i'm saying because i care about
what happens to the rest to this country
what happens to the people she wants to
legalize psilocybin and mdma for study
and that's probably because i mean she
likes it it's the whole premise of that
great show ozark spoiler alert i
apologize but the whole thing is like
we're gonna do all these evil things
because ultimately we'll do good with it
right and we just do evil thing after
evil thing but like one day or it's the
premise of the godfather right one day
we'll be legitimate so in the meantime
i'm gonna kill all of these people but
in the end and i think that's sometimes
how they think they'll ultimately when i
have everything i need all the power all
the wealth i will do good but to get
there i'm just gonna have to kill
several people or i'm going to have to
do fake photo shoots or bomb the system
does it like yeah we talk about her fake
photo shoots
and people just believe it yeah they
just keep believing it she keeps doing
it they keep believing it yeah
i don't know man the funny thing is is
that
members of the house besides the speaker
i mean they're really not very
significant no offense to them but like
anyone who's worked in dc and the polit
like one member of congress and they're
not supposed to be right they're not
supposed to be powerful that's the
problem heck you began the broadcast by
saying you know 2024
we was it's a long ways away and we're
already talking about it we're already
talking about it because everyone knows
how damn powerful the president is
that's why i disagree with you one row i
don't want power in dc i want power in
the states i want way more influence of
my governor and my mayor
because i can i can have impact on that
heck i could run into the mayor of this
town walking down the street but you're
never going to run into the member of
congress it's actually kind of a joke
right you know and you're never going to
run into the president
we shouldn't want these powerful aoc
shouldn't be powerful and the fact that
she's like but i want power to do good
whoa
come on well in her mind good no i don't
think so i don't think she thinks she
just wants power yeah i don't think she
thinks to herself like i'm a good guy at
all i don't think she thinks that much
possible i think she's just like more
followers well she is the prime example
of using the ends to justify the means
and i think based on her photo ops we
can really see and based on the amount
of power that she has like she's a super
social justice um political figure and
she's not using that power for good like
she had a small amount of power and
she's not doing good with it i see no
reason to believe that if she was given
a greater deal of power that she would
do anything different with it
i don't know though i guess she could
change her tune but i have yet to see
people really make introspective changes
like that on this speaker well if i was
kirsten gillibrand who's the senator
from new york which is the next high
powerful position i would be very much
afraid remember she ran for president in
16. remember she had the pride t-shirt
and there was that does that mean
exactly there's the meme of her
pretending that she's really big on
these issues she got crushed in the in
the primary
um but she's done nothing since it's
been
six years i mean she's in she's a
non-entity in the in the senate and if
you're a kirsten gillibrand you should
be petrified to think aoc does have 14
million followers and we're talking
about her and i don't did you ever hear
kirsten gillibrand's name before
you've heard it you've heard of aoc yeah
absolutely so i mean she's going to keep
climbing but i just hope she climbs only
within that hell hole i used to call
home which is new york
wow no offense
i think colbert asked if he's going to
run for president is she old enough to
run for president
so she could run because by the time the
election like a month before the
election she would be 35. so she could
be campaigning all day and night i think
what would would happen and maybe
someone will tell her that politely
is she would have huge momentum
um but ultimately in the presidential
you got to start talking and you and she
would she would embarrass herself so
because she's really not very smart i
think she should do it
she'll she will i think she maybe
someone her advisors will tell her her
flame will go out so poorly it's like
kirsten gillibrand or like kamala
although kamala harris became the vice
president her own state didn't vote for
her because she was so bad in the debate
yeah right um so you can run for
president but you will expose yourself
when people critically ask themselves
like
who's qualified to be president of the
united states it's not going to be a
bartender you know like i appreciate the
work that bartenders do i really do but
when when people when moms and dads are
going to the ballot box and saying who
do i trust do i trust an accountant or
do i trust a bartender to run this
country they're going to pick the
accountant yep
yeah or or someone who at least has a
deep understanding of of the country and
a deep appreciation of it and the thing
i dislike about her which i just like
about the the modern left right now as a
whole is they have genuine disdain for
this country you know they don't they
don't like the country they think the
country is racist sexist whatever they
don't celebrate they don't have red
white and blue
right like that new yorker article yeah
they don't they don't they don't
celebrate what america is they think
america needs to be deeply
transformed you know what i love i i
love that they hate this country it's
racist white supremacist evil
fascist homophobic but they desperately
want more people to suffer along with
them coming across the southern border
the left's motto misery loves company we
hate this place so you should come here
is that it you're so right about them
hating the country though in canada it's
the same thing um if you see someone
flying a canadian flag you know they're
a conservative right which is like what
like here i don't know if it's the same
is it it is exactly if you fly an
american flag
right it's the same in the uk as well it
seems like everywhere throughout the
west there's this mindset that oh we
hate this because we've never known
anything else we've never actually known
suffering or struggle we've never lived
in russia we've never lived in you know
any of these small countries that are
really fighting like myanmar like we
haven't seen it and we're just like ah
it's gross well it's still maga month so
that's true that's true yeah that
american flag as your profile picture it
is that's why it was so funny to see
prince harry
today at the u.n larp as an american
exactly talking about how we've
sacrificed our country democracy's under
threat and you want to say
sixth grades great great great great
great great grandfather
caused all this to begin with right if
he weren't a bad guy we probably would
still be part of you so it's it's direct
line to your six-pack great-grandfather
that we're here to begin with so just
shut up harry honestly you know i mean
quite shut up megan that's not harriet
i'm kind of like i'm i don't like
crapping on these people at prince harry
aoc because i feel like they're
massively influential and powerful and
if we don't work with them
the entire system is going to get
smeared
is he powerful though i looked at a
picture of the united nations when harry
was talking and it was empty
i don't think people actually
think that this guy is an intelligent
thoughtful person i think they think
he's someone that goes on oprah and can
get clicks but
when serious people need to listen they
don't yeah he's just uh he's like he he
walked away from the royal family so
he's an example of like freedom over
power kind of person
i don't know if he's a freedom over
power person because he still seems to
let me fix my camera a little bit we're
getting daniel's hat there we go he
still seems to really want a lot of that
power that he willingly gave up by
leaving the royal family and his wife is
was an actress in america so i feel like
they were
trying to be like princess diana or
something i think that's what was going
on there very well i think i think ian
is a plant to try and reconnect with
plants
and subvert the revolution i think this
is i want canada off the british
monarchs
let's do it how do we start i think this
is the biggest part
oh my gosh i yeah no i think that if we
if we just drop tradition i mean i
respect your guys's decisions as
freedom-loving americans to leave i get
it but
part of me you know if you don't if you
don't value that tradition and you know
like the queen back then when you guys
left there's a reason why you did it but
now the queen doesn't have any
strong political power especially not
the governor general that's the head of
state of canada
so you know just getting rid of it is
just playing into the leftist hands who
want to destroy everything that that
attaches us to our past i don't i don't
know if i agree she has no power i mean
she just doesn't use it perhaps and so
you might just think she's not using it
as well she might be on the phone call
with trudeau and she'll be like do it
and he goes yes ma'am there's something
in that red box that she gets every day
right she's looking at something mm-hmm
the uk was facing uh an uprising i
remember was in the 1800s or whatever so
they created the house of commons i'm
not big on british history and so like
if you're a monarch and you're an
absolute ruler and people are screaming
off with their head what's the smart way
to deal with it
you say okay here's what we're going to
do we're going to tell them we're going
to give them power and share it and be
democratic and in parliament all that
stuff and create the house of commons
and y'all will just do as you're told or
will kill you and then what happens is
the people are like yeah we won and the
queen just keeps her mouth shut as she
rules from the shadows
the house of commons was 1341. all right
i was wrong about that i think that was
king john now i could be wrong about
that but maybe it was the 13th richard
that was after king john after king john
but king john signed the magna carta
which was basically saying yeah
you have the king has to have some rules
yeah and then every every monarch from
king john down has ceded an amount of
power one way or another from either
letting parliament exist to
not fighting a war against his own
parliament or and then you get to where
it is now but you know i'm not saying
that you're wrong um what if the
conspiracy is the queen is secretly the
queen
there's a lot of there's a lot of
active investigations into what what
sort of power she exerts over the
british parliament i don't i don't think
that that really extends much to canada
at the time but um you know a lot of her
influence she doesn't ever not sign a
bill that's put on her desk but her
staff are routinely reaching out to
government as bills are being put
forward and
offering their advice and their advice
is often like canada uh no the br the
british british parliament uh they're
much more interested in that i don't
think she gives canada much of a thought
i bet she does i'm sure deep down the
queen is the queen the uh it's british
columbia
like the idea is like we know she's a
queen but we just don't think she does
anything and it's like but like why do
you really think that you know like
it's not that far-fetched to think the
queen actually just makes a phone call
and says hey we're doing this you just
you should do this too and they say okay
yeah you know i mean it's her majesty's
prisons it's her majesty's armed forces
right ships it's hers
that's all hers
which is pretty cool
i'm glad we don't have her don't get me
wrong i think she's a lovely woman from
a distance yeah although what happens
all the commonwealth countries are woke
yeah i think she's i really think she's
great i think she's done a great job
over the course of 70 years or whatever
it's been but i'm really fearful what
what comes after her what what happens
with prince charles what happened i i
like prince william a little bit more
than prince charles but prince charles
is like right up right up there with the
rest of the world economic forum and
yeah
i don't know if you want to get into
that i often tweet photos of charles's
many properties and the ones he will
inherit because also he cares deeply
about the climate issue um
and it's it's wonderful to care about
climate change from like your 30 000
acre estate with with servants and he's
like oh this whole garden is organic
it's like yesterday well that's flawless
i don't care what we're talking about
we're talking about prince charles
inheriting the the empire of britain as
if it's okay it's not okay for a person
to own that spoken like a true american
sound like a child
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you